[Musique]
tout sexy dans olé qu'elle a découvert
une enveloppe thierry contient aussi des
intercités et très riche il y a quelques
années on les venir est aujourd'hui on
n'en parle presque plus mais où sont
donc les antioxydants la toute première
fois qu'on a parlé d'antioxydants à la
télé de radio canada c'était à
l'émission découverte en 1996 par les
années 80 il ya eu un gros boum
scientifique autour d un siècle c'est un
plusieurs nouvelles recherches qui ont
été publiés et qui ont démontré tout le
potentiel en fait de ces petites
molécules me rock presque j'ai envie de
dire dans plusieurs aliments en
particulier dans les fruits et légumes
certains aliments avait un pouvoir
antioxydant clame-t-on haut et fort il
avait le pouvoir de nous protéger contre
les radicaux les radicaux libres c'est
quoi ces des molécules qui sont créés
dans notre corps de façon naturelle
ces petits radicaux les brûle quand il
se met quand même en avoir beaucoup ils
peuvent se mettre attaquer nos cellules
nos les antioxydants arrive dans
l'histoire c'est que les autres
accidents nous protègent contre l'effet
des radicaux les grosso modo les
radicaux libres se met à attaquer
l'antioxydant plutôt que d'attaquer
notre cellule donc l'on avait démandé
étude qui montrait mange des fruits des
légumes c'est bon les frais les légumes
contiennent des antioxydants et les
autres accidents sur des cellules et des
souris ça protège contre le cancer
donc en s'oxydant protège contre le
cancer
on faisait cette association là
exactement mais c'est une hypothèse
steptoe la vérité c'est l'industrie des
produits de santé naturels qui a d'abord
pris la balle au bond dans les années 90
on en a vu apparaître partout beaucoup
de supplément de
vitamine c vitamine de sélénium ecce
terra puis l'industrie agroalimentaire
évidemment repris la balle parce que
ultime en la source originale de ces
fameuses petites molécules c'est les
aliments donc c'était pertinent que
l'industrie veuille d utiliser pili même
temps les produits
mais voilà on réalise aujourd'hui qu'on
a fait fausse route
ce qui nous manquait à l'époque des
études sur l'être humain et ça ça a été
fait dans les dernières décennies
ce qu'on s'est rendu compte en testant
chez l'humain c'est que ça pas d'effet
on ne voit pas de défait de prévention
des maladies cardiovasculaires ou du
camp sacs mais ce qu'on démontre aussi
par les études ce que je pris sous forme
de suppléments alimentaires
il ya même un risque s'est produit ce
qu'on a donné des suppléments
d'antioxydants et les gens ça augmenter
leurs risques de certains types de
cancer notamment que les suppléments de
vitamine a et de vitamine e qui sont des
insectes blanc une autre des
problématiques au fait d'avoir utilisé
les antioxydants c'est que les gens se
sont mis à croire qu'ils avaient des
aliments qu'ils étaient plus importants
que d'autres
dans leur alimentation donc de croire
que le thé vert ou le curcuma c'était
miraculeux
quand tu y penses c'est un peu comme les
potions magiques qu'on confesse dans le
temps se basant sur ces nouvelles études
le gouvernement canadien a resserré ses
règles il y environ 10 ans plus question
que les compagnies agroalimentaires
puisse aller dit n'importe quoi sur
leurs produits donc plein entreprises
agroalimentaires qui en pole choix de
sortir de ça ou qui ne voyaient plus
bénéficier la réglementation canadienne
est clair il est interdit de faire des
allégations santé vague les entreprises
pour plusieurs enquêtes prennent un peu
un détour
c'est à dire qu'ils vont jouer soit sur
le nom de la marque nous ajouter des
petit logo qui nous suggère un bénéfice
quelconque qui est en lien avec les
ingrédients actifs produits je pense à
oasis dans sa gamme poids pour santé
donc ça a été un des premiers produits
qu'on a vu sur le marché qui alléguait
clairement la présence d'antioxydants le
produit existe toujours donc si il
s'appelle antioxydants on n'a pas le mot
complet l'ajustement qui a été fait par
contre c'est que maintenant on a
clairement sur l'emballage la précision
de quel type antioxydant et dedans et en
quelle quantité donc pas d'allégations
fonctionnel
qui se trouve en fait on ne dise pas ce
que ça va faire dans notre corps mais on
nous dit qu y en a et combien ils
gagnent donc ça c'est permis autre
exemple aussi qu'on connaît bien c'est
les fameux biscuit petits biscuits en
quarts prévention de leclerc et parmi
leurs gammes de petits biscuits il y en
a un qui est au chocolat noir et vin
rouge donc qui lui aussi a leg la
présence d'antioxydants
à l'époque il y avait des allégations
fonctionnel sur le produit s'est
maintenant retirée mais comme pour oasis
on à la précision de la quantité et de
la nature des antioxydants qui sont dans
le produit
ça s'est permis un petit logo encore et
toujours là qui nous laisse croire que
c'est bon pour la santé cardiovasculaire
effectivement comment gérer une
stratégie que plusieurs entreprises
agroalimentaires pourront utiliser non
plus donc prendre les mots et les
allégations qui sont pas le droit de
dire mais de suggérer notamment par des
symboles ou simplement par la présence
d'ingrédients qui sont reconnus comme
étant riche en antioxydants les seuls
produits pouvant faire des allégations
santé sont ceux enregistrés comme
produits naturels j'ai emporté avec moi
une fois de tva qui allègue très très
clairement anti oxydants une source
d'antioxydants pour le maintien d'une
bonne santé
en principe sur un aliment ce n'est pas
permis pourquoi est-ce que celui en fait
c'est le petit code kit cnbm avec des
chiffres qui suit ce que ça nous dit en
fait c'est que ce produit là n'est pas
enregistrée comme un aliment mais comme
un produit de santé naturel mais ici
aussi
aucune preuve que ce thé vous protégera
contre certaines maladies
quelles seraient vos recommandations en
fait je salue quand même bien une
cassette mais j'ai pas le choix de la
répéter la fameuse phrase manger des
fruits et légumes frais mangez en
revanche les uns et manger dans millas
ans a évolué mais c'était une erreur à
la base de commencer à des enfin on a
trouvé la solution de ce qu'il faut
tirer comme leçon c'est dire que on ne
va jamais trouvé c'est quoi la molécule
ou la classe de molécules qui est
importante parce que c'est manger des
aliments antique est important pas
manger des molécules